the jurogan experience you know it's
it's it's the space between the notes
right that's what they talk about with
jazz
right the space between the notes
utica that's the same thing yeah we both
did bro
the same thing with stand-up it's the
space between the jokes even it's a
space between the ideas
like stand-up is um the thing that
requires
a lack of discipline sometimes like
stand up is not just
it's like jazz and uh
anytime you're playing a musical
instrument you must be proficient
wait a minute what is that marijuana no
but i mean what
comes from donald rawlings that's some
good [ __ ] man let's go show right
that's good for now i've got a monitor
i'm gonna i'm gonna monitor that
hit and uh good call yeah stand-up
requires
almost a lack of discipline to be
wild enough to say some of the [ __ ] that
we say
but also discipline to go over your
notes
discipline to look at all these ideas
and try to structure them in a way
that's going to resonate with the
audience you know and then also
discipline to like
think about the set and what went wrong
what went right and trying to
re-evaluate
so the words in stand-up and the ideas
that's where your fingers are on the
piano
right that's that's the technical side
and then
the spaces between the words and the
rhythm
and the timing with the audience that's
where
yeah also your head right yeah like
where your head's at
because i you know like i mean again
like i've had a you know
i've i've had i've enjoyed making music
over the years i wouldn't say that i'm
that good at it but i definitely love
doing it and
you can pull up pull up my video from
1992 of
when i was a kid in in canada i made a
rap album and to me
it was like i love this i loved it it
was
it was sort of like the technology like
i loved i loved like i got a sampler i
worked all summer as a
mowing lawn so i could buy a sampler a
used sampler and then i started sampling
records listening to gangstar and like
i'm going to try to do that you know and
uh and so
uh oh um so uh but uh you know man
like um yeah there this is that's me in
the red jacket
when i was 18 years old
and oh well you know this was our album
that's 1990
1991 that's the yellow jacket look how
skinny i am
1 18 of a megapixel camera yeah yeah
well it's it's a bad upload we actually
shot it so shot on film actually that
was shot on
16 millimeter film on a steady cam
there we go yeah they're me
in their grocery store are you friends
with these guys anymore yeah yeah yeah
yeah greg's
greg campbell is the other emcee he's a
great rapper
what's he doing though he is in ottawa
and uh he's he's
actually killing it as a real estate
agent up there and he's doing a great
job he really is killing it like i mean
it is his
he's uh so uh mr big stuff he called
himself after
he's he's he's an incredible rapper
actually did you call himself mr big
stuff when you're selling houses you
should man
it's a good idea to show up with a clock
on your neck he still has
i'd like you to meet greg someday okay
he's still got like an incredible
energy about him and i feel like in a
lot of ways like
i like i learned a lot from him we were
kids you know but we met in high school
we were we were skateboarders and uh he
was other skateboarders he's a couple
years younger than me
like he's like and when we were like
when i was 17 and he was 15 we went to
new york and
made a made a goofy record so wow and
he's got
there there we are that's greg on the
right and that's my jordy ferguson who
i've happened to talk talk he was our dj
in the middle
and but greg on the right in the glasses
where are you hilarious that's me on the
left [ __ ] out of here boom
see it says i see your face look at me
barely you can see it says bones on my
hat that's because that's from paul
peralta skateboard so i just
but i was bones mc bones because i was
skinny
bones rocking the microphone i'm like a
king on the throne only thing is i stand
alone
you know what i'm saying joe i do
understand i get it
this was our pizza commercial we did we
did a pizza a lot we did a local pizza
commercial
you could play amazing is the pizza
company still around the pizza store it
was for a grocery store chain called
uh loeb look at you you can play this
you can play this video
look play can you play that can you play
with the music we wrapped in it
uh yeah check this out
with the cool food 9.99
dude you did a pizza commercial as a
rapper
look at me 19. did that kid really need
glasses or was that a problem
uh i don't think that was me that kid
right there
where the other one right there where
they going no no greg needed glasses
yeah okay those were a real document
yeah i really just trust people with
faces keep it real man we keep a real
organization
oh yeah wouldn't you get a little uneasy
they're trying to be like john lennon or
something or
i don't know why i would get uneasy um
yeah why
episodes of the joe rogan experience are
now free on spotify
that's right they're free from september
1st to december 1st they're going to be
available everywhere but after december
1st they will only be
available on spotify but they will be
free that includes the video the video
will also be there
it'll also be free that's all we're
asking just go
download spotify much love